[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mes amis nous sommes donc en normandie
et nous lançons notre campagne des
européennes chez vous hervé l'a dit
c'est une terre de conquérant et bien ça
tombe bien nous avons un appétit de
conquête et quand je vous écoute est les
uns les autres comme je sentais la façon
dont vous étiez concentré quand les uns
et les autres s'exprimer quand je
retrouvais dans l'ambiance que nous
avons ce soir
cette envie et cet enthousiasme que
j'aime tant dans la politique quand je
vous vois venus si nombreux
quand je nous vois rassembler comme nous
ne l'avons jamais été
depuis si longtemps je sens une chose je
sens qu'il ya dans cette campagne des
européennes une liste qui est porté par
une dynamique
je sens qu'il ya dans cette campagne des
européennes une liste qui est porté par
une vraie envie je sens qu'il ya dans
cette campagne des européennes
une seule liste qui permet de faire
bouger les lignes c'est la nôtre et
c'est grâce à votre engagement
là où ça se passe là où les choses sont
en train de bouger
c'est du côté de notre liste de la liste
portée par françois xavier bellamy de la
liste de rassemblement des républicains
et du centre merci de nous avoir permis
de conjurer ainsi tous les scénarios
parce que les scénarios il y en avait il
nous avait promis au pire et pourtant
sondage après sondage
notre liste ne fait que progresser
depuis le moment où nous l'avons
présentée mais cela ce n'est pas qu'une
affaire de petite cuisine politicienne
il ya quelque chose de plus profond qui
se joue au fond pourquoi sommes nous là
parce que chacun d'entre vous vous
refusez qu on vous confisque votre choix
pourquoi sommes nous là mais parce que
chacun d'entre vous vous refusez l'idée
que la démocratie française soit
condamné à la réédition du second tour
de la présidentielle
pourquoi sommes nous là parce que la
politique ça ne peut pas devenir être
condamné au choix entre d'un côté le
chaos de marine le pen et la désillusion
des manuels macron raymond aron ce
philosophe qui avait toujours refusé de
céder face au communisme l'avait très
bien compris le choix en politique n'est
pas entre le bien et le mal
pourquoi sommes nous là parce que nous
voulons rendre aux français le choix
parce que dans cette élection européenne
si les républicains et les centristes
sont de retour
c'est pour proposer autre chose de
retour pour refonder l'europe et
rétablir la france de retour pour que
les français aient un vrai choix et que
personne ne leur dicte ce qu'ils ont à
faire
lors d'une élection il n'y a pas une
seule alternative dans cette campagne
des européennes
nous avons le choix et nous allons leur
montrer que le choix est du côté des
républicains
[Applaudissements]
car de l'autre côté
comment ne pas le sentir c'est une
double impasse la première impasse c'est
évidemment celle de marine le pen marine
le pen pour laquelle la déconstruction
de l'europe serait la solution pour
établir la france mais elle n'a pas
compris précisément que face aux défis
de l'histoire nous avons besoin hervé
plus que jamais de l'europe pour
répondre à la pression de la chine et
des états unis pour faire face au défi
climatique pour nous protéger face à une
immigration de masse que nous n'arrivons
plus intégré nous n'avons sans doute
jamais eu autant besoin de ce qu'était
la promesse de la construction
européenne or ce que propose marine le
pen c'est bien la déconstruction de
l'europe ne nous y trompons pas le
discours en apparence a changé parce que
tout le monde se souvient de ce qu'était
la débâcle du débat du second tour de la
présidentielle mais la réalité reste
toujours la même
elle ne parle plus de sortie de l'euro
mais elle dit qu'elle veut retrouver la
souveraineté monétaire mais ne dupont
pas les français
qu'est-ce donc que retrouver sa
souveraineté monétaire si ce n'est des
construire l'euro et la déconstruction
de l'euro serait un chaos pour la france
pour un pays comme le nôtre marqué par
ses déficits et sa dette
cela signifierait des dévaluations cela
signifiera l'appauvrissement du
patrimoine des français
cela signifierait la perte de notre
pouvoir d'achat
nous sommes ici en normandie et il
suffit de regarder de l'autre côté de la
mer pour comprendre ce que signifie pour
un pays
la déconstruction de l'europe lors du
vote du bric site
marine le pen s'en est réjoui comme si
pour elle c'était le modèle à suivre
et bien si nous avons voulu ce matin à
l'est dans le port de ouistreham
pour voir toutes les conséquences
catastrophiques que représente le
rétablissement de nos frontières
c'est pour bien nous gravé dans nos
têtes que la sortie et la déconstruction
de l'europe pour laquelle oeuvre marine
le pen et nicolas dupont aignan serait
un drame pour l'avenir de notre pays
je combats marine le pen dans cette
élection européenne
parce que je ne veux pas de cette sortie
de l'histoire pour la france
une europe mais une europe gérard qui
fonctionne une europe qui correspondent
à l'europe que nous aimions une europe
qui retrouve son sens son souffle sa
mission et c'est là où est la seconde
impasse celle d'emmanuel macron caire
que propose-t-il au fond il n'a pas tiré
les leçons
ce qu'ils proposent c'est toujours plus
de l'europe qui a échoué
il ne comprend pas que nous avons
pourtant besoin de revoir en profondeur
le fonctionnement de l'union européenne
qu elle s en europe
mais l'europe d'emmanuel macron c'est
l'europe de l'élargissement comme s'il
n'avait pas déjà fait rentrer beaucoup
trop de pays au sein de l'union
européenne
mais l'europe d'emmanuel macron c'est
l'europe de la fin des frontières comme
si l'immigration n'était pas devenu un
problème massif et l'europe d'emmanuel
macro c'est l'europe des taxes lui qui
sont dans son discours de la sorbonne a
proposé de créer toute une série de
nouvelles taxes européennes et enfin
l'europe d'emmanuel macron c'est
l'europe de la bureaucratie
avec la création sans cesse de nouvelles
agences européennes depuis 2010 est il
nous a proposé successivement une agence
pour la sécurité alimentaire
une autre pour la protection civile un
office de l'asile une agence pour
l'innovation de rupture
une autorité de contrôle des règles
sociales une agence de protection de la
démocratie comme si la démocratie avait
besoin d'une agence pour la protéger une
banque du climat un conseil de
l'innovation et j'en passe d'autres
comme je regarde les discordes emmanuel
macron sur l'europe il y a une chose que
je comprends très clairement
vous n'avez pas fini de payer des impôts
et le plus triste c'est que cette voix
de la france est devenue isolé gérard tu
l'as si bien démontré
nous nous sommes mis à dos tous nos
partenaires nous nous sommes mis à dos
l'italie et la hongrie en leur donnant
des leçons
les pays scandinaves en leur expliquant
comment il fallait piloter une économie
le benelux en ne comprenant pas le
respect pour les pays
modeste et même notre partenaire
allemand et pourquoi cela
mais tout simplement parce que la france
ne peut pas prétendre donner des leçons
aux autres
si nous ne sommes pas capables d'abord
de nous les appliquer à nous-mêmes
comment la france pourrait elle
prétendre entraîné un projet européen
nous qui avons pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'euro le pire
déficit budgétaire de la zone euro est
tout à la fois le record véronique de la
dépense publique et des prélèvements
obligatoires
oui mes amis oui mes amis et cela
devrait ouvrir les yeux à bien des
français
l'europe au début quand elle a vu
arriver emmanuel macron à espérer elle a
espéré qu'il allait réformer et elle a
découvert qu'il parlait elle a découvert
qu'il parlait mais qu'il n'agissait pas
et la déception s'est installée
aujourd'hui la voix de la france est
désespérément solitaire quand elle parle
à bruxelles
je n'ai pas oublié cette époque où
nicolas sarkozy avec la présidence
française de l'union européenne avait
permis à la france de réoccuper le
premier rôle sur la scène européenne
comme aujourd'hui
ce temps semble loin
françois-xavier tu l'as dit il ya un
point essentiel
trop peu souvent relevé à ce stade dans
les commentaires nous voulons une france
influente sur la scène européenne
eh bien à bruxelles au parlement
européen à strasbourg
il y as uniquement deux groupes
parlementaires qui compte il n'y en a
pas trois il n'y en a que deux qui
compte
le premier c'est le groupe socialiste et
le deuxième c'est le parti populaire
européen et bien emmanuel macron
envisage de siéger ni dans l'un ni dans
l'autre
pour servir ces petites ambitions il a
prévu de créer son propre groupe nous
dit il qui serait vraisemblablement un
des plus petits groupes parlementaires
européens
un des plus petits groupes
parlementaires européens pour un pays
comme la france mais notre pays s'il
veut défendre ses intérêts il doit être
en première division
je refuse que nous soyons relégué au bas
du tableau ce qui signifie que toutes
les voix qui se porteront sur la liste
dans marche sont des voix qui condamne
la france à ne pas faire entendre et
défendre ses intérêts sur la scène
européenne nous mes amis nous
appartenons au grand parti européen
nous sommes les héritiers de cette
tradition du gaullisme et de la
démocratie chrétienne dont vous pouvez
être fiers et je ne veux pas que des
aventures politicienne individuel
condamne la france au silence de
l'europe
le vote pour la liste des républicains
et des centristes c'est le seul vote qui
permettra à la france de se faire
entendre à bruxelles
alors oui une double impasse marine le
pen et le chaos
emmanuel macron et la désillusion est
l'un et l'autre se font la courte
échelle
le progressiste donneurs de leçons qui
fait le jeu du populiste qu'il exècre
comme le diagnostic est si bien résiste
de bray ils se tiennent l'un et l'autre
dans le précipice vers lequel ils
veulent abîmé la france ils font danser
l'un et l'autre notre démocratie au
dessus du volcan
eh bien je veux leur expliquer je veux
leur expliquer que nous avons compris
que ce destin là ne rimait à rien que
nous avons compris que tout ceci
s'apparentaient à des postures on a même
découvert cette semaine cruelle ironie
que celle qui faisait des leçons de
morale à tout le monde en expliquant
qu'elle était la chantre du progressisme
et bien ce n'est même plus le choix
entre l'extrême droite et le
progressisme
mais le choix entre l'extrême droite et
des anciens d'extrême droite car mes
amis
comble de l'ironie voilà que l'on
apprend que la tête de liste dans marche
dont le seul programme expliqué à ce
stade était de battre le rassemblement
national est en réalité une ancienne
militante d'extrême droite alors je
laisse chacun juge de cela et je laisse
les français jugent de se poser
simplement cette question peut-on encore
accorder le moindre crédit à madame
loiseau après cela et surtout mes amis
je ne veux pas que nous nous résignons à
ça je ne veux pas que la politique se
deviennent cela pourquoi est ce que j'ai
fait avec tous ceux qui sont ici ce
choix pourquoi ai-je fait ce choix de
proposer à françois-xavier de piloter
notre liste parce que je suis convaincu
que nous avons une responsabilité
cette responsabilité c'est celle de
refuser que la politique s'abîme sans
cesse un peu plus dans les petites
phrases qu'elle s'abîme sans cesse un
peu plus dans les turpitudes qu'elle
s'abîme sans cesse un peu plus dans les
doubles discours la responsabilité qui
est la nôtre dans cette élection
européenne
c'est de relever le niveau de la
politique la responsabilité qui est la
nôtre dans cette élection européenne
c'est de faire le choix de refonder
l'europe et pour cela j'ai voulu ce trio
j'ai voulu ce trio avec arnaud danjean
spécialiste de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
j'ai voulu ce trio avec agnès séverin
tient car d'une nouvelle génération
dynamique qui a créé son entreprise et
j'ai voulu ce trio avec françois-xavier
bel ami et je ne suis pas déçu j'étais
sûr qu'on pouvait lui faire confiance
parce que j'étais sûr que quelqu'un qui
a une colonne vertébrale ne peut que
réussir en politique et je remercie
françois xavier d'avoir pris ce risque
insensé et d'avoir redonné ainsi une
telle énergie et une telle envie à notre
famille politique autour du
rassemblement entre la droite
le centre alors oui avec le recul
tout cela paraît évident et vous le
savez ce choix n'a pas été facile et les
bons choix en politique sont rarement
des choix facile pourquoi les faits
parce que je crois profondément qu on ne
reconstruit pas de la politique en
france
quand on esquive quand on fait le choix
de personnalités filandreuse quand on
propose un petit filet d'eau tiède quand
on finit par ne plus comprendre ce qu'on
veut dire parce que précisément soi même
on ne sait pas pourquoi l'on est là j'ai
suis convaincu que la pierre de touche
de la reconstruction de notre famille
politique elle passe à l'image de
françois xavier à l'image d'agnès à
l'image d'arnaud à l'image de françoise
que j'ai tellement de plaisir à
retrouver à l'image de guillaume de
pascal de anne cécile à l'image de
geoffroy qui est ici je suis convaincu
qu'elle passe par des gens qui sont et
qui incarne la droite des valeurs parce
que tout autre droite est condamné à
l'échec c'est celle qui nous a amenés
dans ces sommes de trahison qui ont
constitué petit à petit les
rassemblement hétéroclite qui font
aujourd'hui la république en marche
je crois tout autre chose je crois que
la droite pour se redresser
doit assumer ses idées sereinement mais
avec la plus grande clarté une droite
qui ne marche pas à l'ombre et qui a
retrouvé la fierté de ses idées qu'elle
avait perdue au moment de la
présidentielle et de cet échec funeste
qui nous a tant marqué
mais ce dont je suis encore plus fier
c'est que nous ayons pu le faire en
étant tous rassemblés merci à toi joël
merci d'être là
toi qui est le maire de caen et qui
réussit si bien avec lequel on peut
avoir parfois des différences de penser
mais qui est ici clairement si nettement
présent à nos côtés avec à côté de toi
antoine ruffenach qui nous a ramené à
l'époque dans la clarté cette formidable
victoire du havre cette ville qui l'a
transformée et qui reste pour moi un
repère dans notre vie politique
à l'image de nos élus locaux qui sont
ici mr modeste conseillers
départementaux présidente département à
l'image de toi hervé l'héritier de
guillaume le conquérant
rien de moins pour le président de la
première région de france monsieur hervé
morin je vais vous faire une confidence
il ya au premier rang de personnes qui
sont nettement plus importants que vous
et moi c'est jules et alma les deux
enfants d'hervé morin et j'ai adoré la
question que m'a posé allemand qui m'a
dit est ce que c'est vrai que mon papa
est le président de tous les présidents
oui alma ton papa est le président de
tous les présidents
tu peux être très fiers de lui
merci à toi surtout énervé parce que ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose de très important
ce que nous marquons c'est la fidélité à
ce qu'elle le semble dans notre vie
politique
le centre ça n'est pas un non lieu dans
la vie politique française
le centre c'est un espace de valeurs et
de convictions le sens dans la vie
politique française cela a toujours été
le centre droit tu y est toujours resté
fidèle et la graine que nous plantons
aujourd'hui c'est une graine sur
laquelle toi et moi nous voulons ensuite
pouvoir construire cette alternance dont
nous avons besoin
merci à toi hervé de ta réussite en
normandie merci du fait de porter contre
une majorité tellement centralisatrice
le rappel du terrain et merci de ta
fidélité et sa loyauté à nos idées et
aux convictions que nous partageons
merci à vous merci à toi
et enfin je veux remercier devant vous
gérard larcher pour sa présence je dois
beaucoup à gérard sans doute s'en
souvient-il
mais quand j'ai fait mes premiers pas
comme secrétaire d'état à l'emploi la
première personnalité que je suis allé
voir un soir c'est gérard depuis tes
conseils ne ment jamais manqué nous
avons eu parfois des différences légère
mais nous nous sommes toujours retrouver
et j'ai toujours pu compter sur toi dans
les moments importants
ton engagement plein et entier aux côtés
de françois xavier est un exemple qui
nous honore et qui rappelle que dans
notre famille politique il y a toujours
cette obligation d'être ensemble
c'est l'exemple que tu marques
aujourd'hui ce soir en montrant
clairement que la droite et le centre
sont une famille rassemblée
c'est une immense fierté que de pouvoir
la voir à travers l'incarnation du
président du sénat merci à toi fait rare
refonder l'europe est bien dans cette
campagne nous sommes les seuls à parler
d'europe
les autres parlent d' union européenne
il parle de bruxelles il parle de la
commission européenne il parle de
fédéralisme de souverainisme mais il ne
parle pas d'europe car l'europe c'est
autre chose
l'europe ce n'est pas sans l'europe
c'est une âme
l'europe c'est un mode de vie l'europe
c'est une culture
l'europe c'est des racines quant au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
sur les ruines des villes détruites
les pères fondateurs de l'europe décide
d'inscrire sur ce drapeau bleu les
étoiles de la couronne de la vierge
ils ont conscience qu'ils font autre
chose que ce qu'ils font ça n'est pas
d'abord une construction administrative
ce qu'ils portent d'abord c'est une
démarche de civilisation c'est un projet
de culture et d'identité
tout à la fois et bien la question qui
était celle des pères fondateurs au
lendemain de la destruction du
totalitarisme c'est la même qui
s'adressent à nous c'est exactement la
même question qui nous traversent et
quand nous regardons nos enfants ne nous
posons la même question est ce que nous
pourrons à notre tour transmettre ce
mode de vie et cette civilisation
nous voulons redonner un souffle nouveau
rond auront donné une voix nous voulons
organiser la renaissance de l'europe et
nous voyons les menaces les concurrence
étrangère la menace de l'islamisme le
décrochage parfois de notre économie et
nous nous souvenons alors que l'europe
ça n'est pas qu'une collection de
peuples qui n'ont de commun qu'un non
mais c'est une société réelle qui à sa
religion ses moeurs ses coutumes
ce que rousseau avait compris bien avant
l'institution de la commission
européenne alors quand on
vous demande quelle europe voulez-vous
et bien répondait l'europe que nous
voulons c'est celle de l'identité
quand on vous demande quelle robe
voulez-vous et bien répondons l'europe
que nous voulons c'est l'europe qui
fonctionnait parce qu'elle savait qui
elle était c'était l'europe à laquelle
nous étions attachés parce qu'elle était
capable de porter ses intérêts et simple
et sa puissance dans le monde l'europe
que nous voulons c'est celle des projets
qui nous rendent fiers l'europe que nous
voulons c'est celle de la civilisation
quand on vous demande l'europe que vous
voulez répondez cela nous voulons
l'europe de la civilisation une
civilisation c'est d'abord des
frontières compte romulus et rémus
fondre hommes il commence par tracer un
sillon pour définir ce qui est dedans et
ce qui est dehors et pour signifier
clairement à tous qu'ils seront les
seuls à décider de qui rentrera à
l'intérieur de la cité
sans frontières l'europe ne peut pas
être l'europe et je le dis en marche n'a
pas tiré les leçons des échecs de
l'élargissement emmanuel macron a plaidé
pour l'ouverture des négociations
d'adhésion avec l'albanie et la
macédoine
lors de son discours de trieste ces
négociations débuteront comme par hasard
en juin prochain au lendemain des
élections européennes on connaît
difficilement pire cynisme à bucarest
il a expliqué que la roumanie et la
bulgarie devait rentrer au plus vite
dans l'espace schengen et bien ce soir
je pose une question claire et nous ne
laisserons pas madame l'oiseau se
dérober face à cette question claire est
ce que le président de la république
s'engage à opposer son veto comme il
peut le faire à l'ouverture des
négociations d'adhésion avec l'albanie
qui sont prévues en juin 2019
les électeurs ont le droit à voir cette
réponse au moment où ils voteront
la nôtre je vous la donne avec la plus
grande simplicité tous ceux qui sont sur
notre liste se sont engagés à signer une
charte dans laquelle pendant la totalité
de leur mandat ils voteront contre toute
décision qui aboutirait à ouvrir la voie
à des élargissements supplémentaires il
est temps de tirer les leçons des
erreurs de l' élargissement sans fin de
l'europe savoir quelles sont nos
frontières c'est bien et se donner les
moyens de les contrôler et c'est tout
aussi important nous sommes allés à
lesbos dans ces îles qui sont face à la
turquie on l'envoie au fond tout ce qui
est tout à la fois la détresse et
l'hypocrisie de ce qu'est devenu notre
politique migratoire européenne
ces îles qui sont confrontés à une
immigration illégale qui arrivent chaque
jour avec ce cortège de drames
à l'image d'ailleurs de ces visages
hagards que l'on voit traîner autour de
ouistreham et qu'ils sont des êtres
déracinés qui d'ailleurs portent en eux
souvent bien des stigmates de souffrance
et de drames qu'ils ont dû vivre pour
essayer de passer la méditerranée et de
venir ici je ne sous-estime rien de ses
draps et personne ne peut rester
indifférent face à ce qui se joue dans
la méditerranée mais je pose cette
question quelle est la vraie générosité
la vraie générosité ça n'est pas
d'inciter les jeunes africains à
traverser la méditerranée au péril de
leur vie la vraie générosité c'est de se
battre pour que l'europe accompagne
l'afrique dans un vrai programme de
développement la vraie générosité c'est
celle qui permet de montrer que l'avenir
de la jeunesse africaine et en afrique
guillaume et non pas en europe parce que
ici nos capacités d'intégration ne nous
permettent plus d'offrir des réussites à
tous ceux qui viennent et que nous
n'arrivons plus à intégrer
chaque année protéger nos frontières
européennes
c'est évidemment une nécessité daniel
est ce que nous proposons c'est une
double protection de notre frontière
nous sommes les seuls à proposer cela
dans cette campagne des européennes
d'abord une protection européenne parce
qu'évidemment marine le pen a tort de ne
pas vouloir que l'europe protège nos
frontières tout ce qui passe par la
grèce par l'italie par l'espagne
arriveront ensuite chez nous il faut
évidemment une protection européenne de
nos frontières pour reconduire de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée les
bateaux qui tentent de venir chez nous
pour signifier clairement que les
demandes d'asile doivent être faite de
l'autre côté et non pas sur le continent
européen et pour dire clairement que
toute personne qui sera rentré
irrégulièrement sur le sol européen ne
pourra plus ensuite se voir régulariser
mais la deuxième chose mais la deuxième
chose pour laquelle nous plaidons c'est
également une protection nationale parce
qu emmanuel macron à tort d'expliquer
qu'il faut juste répartir les migrants
entre les pays membres
parce que nous considérons que chaque
pays a ni a aussi le droit de protéger
ses frontières contre l'immigration
irrégulière philippe et c'est pour cela
que nous voulons une protection à la
fois nationales qui nous permettent
juste de contrôler nos frontières pour
empêcher les migrants illégaux de passer
par les pyrénées par les alpes ou par
nos différentes frontières une double
protection parce que c'est plus efficace
une double protection parce que c'est le
symbole de ce que nous voulons pour
l'europe une double protection parce que
c'est tout à la fois l'europe et la
nation une double protection parce que
l'europe contrairement à marine le pen
c'est pour nous un bouclier une double
protection parce qu'il ne faut jamais
renoncer à l'autonomie des nations une
double protection parce que nous croyons
qu'il faut à la fois conjuguer la force
de nos nations et la puissance de la
protection européenne
nous sommes les seuls à apporter cette
réponse claire à la crise de schengen et
à la crise migratoire
[Applaudissements]
et pour qu'une civilisation vive il faut
autre chose il faut des projets et petit
à petit sans même nous en apercevoir
nous avons laissé l'europe des bureaux
se substitue à l'europe des projets ce
que tocqueville appelait et j'aime ces
formules truculente ces petites règles
compliquées minutieuse uniforme qui
gênent comprime énerve et finissent par
éviter oui malheureusement pour bien nos
compatriotes l'europe c'est devenu cela
et ne la comprennent plus parce qu'ils
croient en une autre europe celle des
projets c'est cette europe que nous
voulons rétablir
cela suppose d'abord de revoir les
compétences la commission européenne
doit avoir moins de compétences dans le
domaine normatif
mais elle doit en revanche savoir plus
de compétences pour porter les produits
pourquoi la commission européenne ne se
saisit t'elle pas de la question de la
couverture en 5 g et en internet très
haut débit de l'ensemble du continent
européen
tout le monde lui serait reconnaissante
de porter ce projet pourquoi la
commission européenne ne pourrait-elle
pas porter directement de grands projets
d'infrastructure m par exemple les
camions sur des infrastructures de fer
routage faire en sorte d'aménager les
grands canaux à l'image du canal de la
seine de la seine nord qui pourrait
représenter pour nous quelque chose
contribuer comme elle a déjà commencé à
le faire aménager les grands ports
européens au soutient hervé de ce que
toi tu fais dans notre région pourquoi
l'europe ne se doteraient t'elle pas
d'une ambition pour chacun de ses
mandats une grande cause régionale et
pourquoi cette grande cause ne
serait-elle pas par exemple comme nous
le proposons celle de lutter en commun
pour découvrir les réponses à alzheimer
et aux maladies neurodégénératives ces
maladies qui sont des fléaux terrible
pour notre société dans laquelle on voit
partir jour après jour lettre faire et
dans lequel chaque jour qui passe est un
jour qui efface les souvenirs ou à
l'arrivée il ne reste plus que levinas
appelait les changes par le regard et on
a l'impression d'avoir été dépossédés
ce qu'on avait en commun cette maladie
est le défi du 21e siècle et bien moi je
rêve d'une europe qui apporte à nouveau
la démonstration de son utilité en
montrant sa capacité à faire travailler
tous les laboratoires européens en
commun pour que nous découvrions
ensemble dans les cinq ans qui viennent
les remèdes et les réponses qui peuvent
être apportées à la maladie d'alzheimer
voilà deux grands projets et de grandes
ambitions pour une europe qui a retrouvé
son sens et dans ses projets
françois-xavier tu l'as si bien dit on
ne peut pas accepter que l'europe
continue à être une passoire économique
on ne peut pas accepter que notre destin
se joue dans la silicon valley ou en
chine
on ne peut pas accepter se résigner à ce
que ce soit donald trump qui décide pour
l'europe
les pays avec lesquels elle a le droit
de commercer les pays avec lesquels elle
n'a pas le droit de commercer nous
sommes le continent européen il ne faut
pas que l'europe devienne petit à petit
un continent de consommateurs où tout
finit par être marchandisé y compris le
corps humain où l'on finit par oublier
que toute société doit d'abord reposé
sur le travail
je ne veux pas d'une europe qui soit
uniquement un continent de supermarché
où l'on pousserait des caddies au milieu
d'aller où tout a été fabriqué ailleurs
je veux que nous retrouvions la fierté
de nos artisans de nos commerçants de
nos entrepreneurs de ceux qui prennent
des risques et je veux qu'une bonne fois
pour toutes on puisse dire à la chine
mais vous n'acceptez pas que nous
puissions investir chez vous comme cela
vous n'acceptez pas que nous puissions
vendre nos produits comme cela chez vous
eh bien ce sont les mêmes règles qui
s'appliqueront dorénavant pour entrer
sur le continent européen
si vos marchés publics ne nous sont pas
ouverts et bien nos marchés publics ne
vous seront pas ouverts et nous
réclamons le droit de réinstaurer une
préférence européenne pour nos
entreprises et nos agriculteurs
[Applaudissements]
et enfin et je finirai par cela le plus
important c'est une civilisation
le plus important c'est une continuité
c'est une fierté
depuis les grecs de l'iliade et
l'odyssée cher françois xavier
toi qui quand même nous a fait l'honneur
dans ce débat france 2 où tout cela
finissait par devenir grotesque ou tel
candidat sortait une paire de menottes
pour illustrer ce qu'il voulait de
l'europe ou tel autre le candidat du
rassemblement national sortait une
passoire rouge ou la candidate dans
marche sortait un extrait de piment
d'espelette
il ya eu enfin quelque chose d'autre qui
est passé quand françois xavier lui a
sorti un livre et ce livre qu'elle livre
c'était le livre de l'iliade pour nous
rappeler que l'europe c'est quand même
autre chose qu'une passoire rouge ou
qu'une collection de piment d'espelette
l'europe c'est une civilisation
merci françois xavier d'avoir redonné un
peu de dignité
à ce moment là dans le débat européen
[Applaudissements]
cette civilisation ne vous y trompez pas
elle est un fruit précieux et fragile
elle est menacée par l'immigration de
masse
elle est menacée par le communautarisme
elle est menacée par le
multiculturalisme
elle est menacée par une mondialisation
aveugle elle est un bien précieux et
elle est un bien que nous pouvons sauver
cela passe
or par le fait d'aimer son identité on
nous a tellement appris depuis tellement
de temps que c'était un gros mot que de
dire que l'on aimait son identité
et bien je vous le dis on a le droit
d'aimer ce que nous sommes
on a même le droit de le chérir à tel
point que l'on ait envie de le
transmettre à ceux qui viendront
dernière nous le président de la
république a dit à lyon qu'il n'y avait
pas de culture française
la tête de liste dans marche dans une
parfaite cohérence avec le président de
la république à l expliquer qu'elle
trouvait que le voile islamique et est
parfaitement comparable à la tenue de
mère teresa ou au fichu de nos grands
mères dans les églises
eh bien je ne partage rien de cela parce
que l'europe ça n'est pas rien ça ne
vient pas de rien parce que l'europe
c'est une construction parce que dans ce
moment étrange où tout le monde
redécouvre comme tu l'a très bien dit au
moment de l'incendié de notre dame
nos racines nous nous avons toujours dit
cela
nous avons toujours dit que l'europe
propose est sûre cela nous sommes même
les seuls à parler dans cette campagne
européenne de culture quand nous
réclamons qu'il y ait un pour cent du
budget européen qu'ils soient réservés à
la culture
quand nous disons que nous voulons que
chaque lycéen sur son parcours qui
l'amène jusqu'à la fin de ses études à
l'université se soient vus proposer la
possibilité de faire 6 mois d'études
dans un pays européens y compris pour
lutter contre les discriminations
sociales qui fait que toute une partie
des enfants des classes moyennes n'ont
pas la possibilité eux d'accéder à ses
études à l'échelle de l'europe parce que
nous voulons qu'ils le reconnaissent ses
racines
j'ai bien dit les racines chrétiennes
parce que l'europe c'est le fruit de ces
trois traditions que tu as évoqué la
tradition de l'antiquité oui la
tradition des lumières évidemment gérard
et la tradition judéo-chrétienne
c'est
une évidence et pourtant nous avons eu
peur de l'inscrire dans les traités
européens
les racines chrétiennes et pourtant
regardez comme nous sommes attaqués
quand nous osons défendre cette petite
tradition qui dit tant de choses nos
crèches et bien je refuse de céder dans
ces moments-là pas parce que c'est une
lubie mais parce que les crèches est un
petit bout de ce que nous sommes et
parce que je suis convaincu qu'à chaque
fois que nous reculons c'est un petit
bout supplémentaire de nous mêmes que
nous abandonnons
vous le savez si vous allez à bruxelles
à deux pas des institutions européennes
il y a aussi un quartier ce quartier
c'est molenbeek ce quartier c'est celui
qui a hébergé les terroristes de
l'intégrisme islamiste qui ont fait tant
de morts en france
ce quartier c'est un quartier qui
devrait nous ouvrir les yeux parce que
pendant très longtemps l'europe avait
vécu selon un très vieux principes
formulés par saint-augustin à rome fais
comme les romains et parce que petit à
petit dans notre folie obsédé par le
fait de sembler tolérant et de croire
que la tolérance et le multiculturalisme
nous avons fait tout l'inversé et que
nous avons laissé s'installer le
communautarisme et bien nous dans cette
élection européenne
nous le disons clairement les nouveaux
arrivants ont une obligation simple et
clair ils doivent faire leur le mode de
vie européen et nous le disons avec la
plus grande clarté
il faut que l'on puisse mettre en place
une charte des valeurs et des devoirs
européen pour que toute personne qui
rentre xavier sur le continent européen
s'engage à le respecter parce que
l'europe ça n'est pas rien parce qu'il y
à chez nous des choses qui ne sont pas
négociables
parce que chez nous l'égalité entre
l'homme et la femme ne sont pas
négociables
parce que le fait qu'une femme puisse
avancer tête nue ciel le souhaitent
n'est pas négociable parce que la
liberté de conscience et la liberté
d'expression ne sont pas négociables et
parce que un intégrisme quel qu'il soit
ne peut dicter sa volonté aux autres
c'est à celui qui vient de l'étranger de
s'adapter à la france et à l'europe
ça n'est pas à la france et à l'europe
de s'adapter à celui qui vient de
l'étranger
et oui cela passe par le fait d'arrêter
de minorer l'islamisme cela passe par le
fait d'arrêter de se soumettre
cela passe par le fait d'arrêter de
faire semblant comme nous le faisons
trop en ce moment en france
cela passe par le fait que l'europe doit
adopter un bouclier contre l'islamisme
comme nous le proposons qui repose
d'abord sur l'idée qu'il faut fermer
toutes les mosquées salafistes d'europe
qui prêchent la haine qui propose
d'arrêter tous les financements
étrangers de l'islam sur le continent
européen et qui propose enfin d'expulser
en dehors du continent européen tous les
imams qui prêchent la violence la haine
l'antisémitisme le rejet de l'autre
ça n'est pas acceptable sur un continent
comme l'europe qui sait trop le prêt
qu'il y ait à payer et tu l'a très bien
dit françois xavier
nous ne prenons pas de leçon de marine
le pen elle qui avec le rassemblement
national depuis cinq ans à bruxelles à
voter systématiquement contre tous les
outils qui aurait permis de protéger
l'europe à l'image de ce qu'elle a fait
en refusant de permettre à l'europe de
se doter des moyens permettant de
contrôler qui monte dans les avions et
qui a osé ensuite l'expliquer en dix ans
les terroristes ne prennent pas l'avion
on se demande comment on peut encore
dire une telle chose
après les attentats du 11 septembre
madame le pen j'ai eu honte quand je
vous ai entendu dire les terroristes ne
prennent pas l'avion et j'ai eu une
pensée pour tous ceux qui avaient perdu
un membre de leur famille à ce moment là
les terroristes prennent l'avion et nous
avons besoin de l'europe pour lutter
contre les terroristes
[Applaudissements]
alors oui finalement notre mission dans
ces européennes celles que nous sommes
les seuls à assumer c'est de retrouver
le goût et le sens de ce que nous sommes
c'est de retrouver l'héroïsme des
spartiates qui refusait de céder un
pouce de terrain de leur chère terre
grecque
menacé par la perse qui voulait mettre à
néant cette civilisation hellénique que
tu aimes tant c'est de retrouver
oui ce qui s'appelle la perfection du
parthénon et la majesté du mont saint
michel
celle d'une culture comparable à nulle
autre et qui a produit parmi les plus
beaux bâtiments qui existent mont saint
michel qui comme tout le monde le sait
est bien évidemment en normandie
l'agressé d'histoire que je suis fait
une petite entorse aux règles de la
géographie qui me seront dûment
reprocher du côté breton bien sûr
puisque comme tout le monde le sait la
bretagne revendique évidemment la
présence du mont-saint-michel monsieur
philippe bas mais l'europe c'est aussi
cette volonté éternelle de perpétuer
l'héritage de l'empiré romain portée de
charlemagne jusqu'à napoléon en passant
par le rayonnement de la papauté
l'europe c'est l'extraordinaire
épanouissement culturel qui commence
avec les gestes du moyen-âge et qui
finit avec les romans de goethe ou de
balzac
l'europe c'est la grandeur de la
peinture de la renaissance de l'âge d'or
espagnol où l'épanouissement du
classicisme français
la redécouverte de l'impressionnisme
l'europe c'est un peu tout cela à la
fois l'europe c'est cette histoire qui
s'est forgée dans les batailles navales
sur la méditerranée en allant jusqu'à
l'art concquis ta aux confins de la
péninsule ibérique
c'est cela le vrai goût de l'europe une
europe dont nous sommes les héritiers
une europe qui nous oblige et une europe
dont un autre tour nous devons être
digne eh bien oui puissions nous retenir
cher françois xavier
cette leçon de notre dame parce qu'il y
avait bien une leçon de notre dame le
message de notre dame c'est celui que tu
as donné
oui si la france brûler c'est parce
qu'avec notre dame c'était toute une
partie de nos racines qui brûlait oui il
y avait bien un message à notre dame
ce message c'est qu'une civilisation
c'est précieux
les âmes il ya des incendies visible il
y à des destructions que tout le monde
comprend mais il y a aussi des incendies
invisible il y à des destructions qui
sont plus lentes
ces destructions ce sont celles qui se
joue dans nos lâchetés et nos
soumissions à chaque fois que l'on
accepte que nos enfants n'apprennent
plus l'histoire de france à chaque fois
que l'on accepte que quelqu'un qui
vienne dans un hôpital refuse que ce
soit un médecin homme qui soigne une
patiente femmes à chaque fois que l'on
accepte qu'un professeur d'histoire ne
puisse plus enseigner l'histoire de la
shoah
à chaque fois que l'on cède 1 pouces de
la laïcité face une minorité qui réclame
son droit à la différence
à chaque fois que l'on laisse reculé
tout à la fois les règles de la france
et de la république
c'est un autre incendie c'est notre
civilisation qui brûle
eh bien je ne veux pas que nous restions
passif face à ces incendies oui rétablir
la france et pour cela refonder l'europe
refonder l'europe et rétablir la france
tout à la fois parce que les deux sont
liés parce que les deux sont liés parce
que refonder c'est vouloir maintenir sa
culture parce que rétablir c'est vouloir
redonner une ambition et un souffle
parce que refonder ses redécouvrir sa
civilisation
parce que l'europe et la france ce n'est
pas un vide parce que nous voulons
retrouver cette envie que nous avions
connu un moment où l'europe était celle
qui s'affirmait alors oui quand pour les
autres leur seul objectif est de battre
la liste qui est en face notre objectif
à nous c'est de réaffirmer l'identité
européenne c'est de retrouver le sens de
notre civilisation en politique mes amis
il ne faut jamais baisser les bras
je n'ai jamais baissé les bras même
quand les sondages nous donnent est au
plus bas
j'étais convaincu qu'il restait les
petites flammes d'un espoir sur laquelle
nous avons rebâti cette remontée qui est
la nôtre depuis l'entrée dans cette
campagne européenne
parce qu'en politique c'est toujours la
force des idées qui finit par gagner
nous en avons vu des batailles et nous
avons tous connu ce moment ce moment
tout semble se suspendre où l'on sent
petit à petit cette petite tension
électrique qui commence à s'installer
dans l'air et où l'on se dit peut-être
que tout est en train de basculer
ce moment tout d'un coup les scénarios
que nous avons que l'on nous avait
prédit sont un train d'être déjoué ce
moment où l'on sent que tout d'un coup
la victoire peut être à portée de main
et bien ce sentiment c'est celui que
nous percevons aujourd'hui je vous le
dis nous allons basculer toutes les
certitudes et nous allons le faire parce
que je suis convaincu que notre cause
est juste
parce que je suis convaincu que l'europe
n'est belle que quand elle est fière
d'elle-même
parce que nous voulons continuer
l'histoire de notre civilisation et lui
redonner un avenir parce que quand on
s'engage en politique je ne connais pas
de plus grand ni de plus beau combat
refonder l'europe rétablir la france
vive l'europe et vive la france
[Applaudissements]